la distancia que una persona puede ver
en un día claro se estima por la fórmula
v es igual a 1.125 raíz cuadrada de a
todo eso sobre 1000 donde b es
visibilidad esta vez de aquí es
visibilidad en millas y ya es altitud
eso está claro ahora nos dicen si
gerónimo puede ver 150 millas eso es qué
tan lejos alcanza a ver esa es la
visibilidad así es que esto es ve a qué
altura sobre el suelo se encuentra así
es que nos están preguntando cuál es la
altitud a qué altura sobre el suelo se
encuentra esta es entonces a la cual
desconocemos sabemos que su visibilidad
es de 150 millas y queremos encontrar a
aquí tenemos esta fórmula de visibilidad
en términos de la altitud sabemos cuál
es la visibilidad es de 150 millas
así es que ve es 150 millas así es que
podemos establecer que ve
o 150 millas es igual
1.225 por la raíz cuadrada de a ya es la
altura a la que se encuentra así es que
por raíz cuadrada de a y todo eso todo
eso sobre 1000 ahora multiplicando ambos
lados de la ecuación lo que queremos es
dejar solo este radical para después
despejar a multiplicando ambos lados
entonces por mil entre mil 225 por 1000
entre mil 225 y también del lado
izquierdo déjame hacerme un poquito
hacia la izquierda por mil entre mil 225
el objeto de esto es dejar sola la raíz
cuadrada de a así es que este mil se
cancela con este mil y este mil 225 con
este mil 225 y que obtenemos no hay me
gusta más dejar del lado izquierdo la
variable que estoy despejando así es que
también voy a invertir los lados de esta
ecuación tenemos entonces del lado
izquierdo la raíz cuadrada de a y del
lado derecho
tenemos este término de aquí este
término de aquí que sería
por 150 y todo eso dividido entre mil
225 entre mil 225 y parece que esto lo
podemos simplificar me parece que estos
dos números son divisibles entre 25
veamos 150 150 es 25 por 6 déjame
escribirlo aquí esto es 25 por 6 y 1.225
2506 25% 1250 es 25 por 50 este número
es 25 - así es que este número es 25 por
49 si es que no me está fallando la
aritmética chequeamos eso por acá 49 por
25 esto es igual a 5 por 9 45 llevamos 4
5 por 4 20 y 4 24 esto ya no me sirve
luego 2 por 9 primero pongo el 0 2 por 9
18 y damos 12 por 4 8 y 1 es 9 hacemos
la suma 5 8 y 4 12 2 y 9 11 y 112 1.225
correcto así es que equipo simplificar
25 y 25 primos déjame deshacer desde
1.225 este 25 se va con este 25 y ahora
me parece que este 49 ya no lo podemos
simplificar más el 7 por 7 así es que
esto ya está en su mínima expresión
así es que esto es igual a 6000 sobre 49
lo cual es igual a la raíz cuadrada de a
ahora si queremos despejar a podemos
elevar al cuadrado ambos lados de la
ecuación déjame reescribir
acá abajo tenemos que la raíz cuadrada
de a es igual a 6000 sobre 49 elevamos a
ambos lados al cuadrado elevamos al
cuadrado la raíz cuadrada de a y
elevamos al cuadrado 6000 entre 49 y que
tenemos esto nos da igual del lado
izquierdo es a la altura sobre el suelo
a la que se encuentra jerónimo y esto es
igual a 6 mil al cuadrado 6000 al
cuadrado sobre 49 al cuadrado o puedes
dividir 6 mil entre 49 y elevarlo al
cuadrado calculemos entonces este valor
para conocer la magnitud de la altura
déjame sacar la calculadora para esto
venga a la calculadora deja de borrar
este comando y ahora si el aquí la
calculadora tenemos entonces 6000
al cuadrado entre 49 al cuadrado y esto
nos da 1400 o más bien voy a redondear
esto es 14 mil 994 pies esto es igual a
14 mil 993 pies y estoy suponiendo que
esta ecuación está considerando que la
altitud está en pies no lo mencionan
aquí pero tiene que estar en pies para
que esto haga sentido si puedes ver
hasta 150 millas hace sentido de que te
encuentras alrededor de 15.000 pies
sobre el piso